back here on the Rich Eisen show Kirk
Morrison filling in for rich just
watching that Wow I'm still shocked I'm
still in silence and I can only imagine
what you kind of felt being there as a
Raja rákóczi marcozzi columnist for the
LA Times joins us now on the Rich Eisen
show and I'm still kind of in shock that
that happened like Clayton Kershaw goes
out there after an unbelievable like no
one you know one batter in the seventh
inning but you're like okay it looks
good
Clayton looks great but he did his job
and so when the eighth inning rolls
around him like are they gonna bring him
back or keep him on a bench because see
other guys warming up in the bullpen and
the decision to bring him out and then
that fast like after the first home run
I was like okay Clayton you're done yeah
if you keep him out there and then that
happens and so you were at the game just
kind of give me just the the mood of not
only the pressbox to say to you Kirk you
touched on it I mean it's we could
debate whether or not he should have
been on the mound to begin but when he
gives up that homerun and there was no
doubt about that homerun to him don't he
comes out it is a short leash for
Clayton Kershaw and then for him to stay
on the mound and then for Soto and we
just touched on it that homerun was not
close one pitch hit was gone so that was
the problem that I have with Dave
Roberts it wasn't just that Clayton was
on the mound but that you didn't pull
him out to that first home run and there
was no doubt about it and then the
second thing the Joe Kelly first of all
Joe Kelly shouldn't have been on the
mound at that point in the game but with
the bases loaded I mean how do you do
that that's that's how when you're
waking up this morning and you're a Los
Angeles sportsman it's one thing if you
lose in the World Series but to lose in
the NLDS after a 106 win season and
because of two really bad decisions that
when you were watching the game in the
press box and you're watching the game
at home how are those guys still on the
mound
we've seen them during the course of
this season they cannot be in that
position
but all right what was the
though of the stadium because I saw
pictures of people running over clayton
kershaw jerseys yeah yeah that was were
they booing Clayton
or were they booing basic Spanish or for
a fanatic and when you're in the like
aftermath of a really tough loss and you
put the blame on Kershaw that happens I
think those fans hopefully will regret
that
Clayton Kershaw will go down as one of
the greatest Dodgers of all time no
doubt about his postseason and he was up
there and he said you could put it on me
I can't listen I have not performed in
the postseason
I don't really hold fan to like that one
fan who puts a jersey on the street you
know but I've never seen a stadium more
depressed and not only that Kirk I've
never seen a clubhouse more depressed
because there was a lot of guys who felt
that this was the year who had been on
the team the last two seasons and they'd
come up just short and they had felt
that this was the year and again going
into the ninth 12 walk-off wins this
season there was no doubt in their mind
that they were gonna win that game so
for them to not only did not win the
game but to lose in the fashion that
they did just a lot more tears than I
had seen in the past a lot more long
hugs because this is at the end of the
road for some of those guys David Freese
Rich Hill guys that may not come back
mmm a rush mark Ozzie columnist for the
LA Times joining us
Kirk Morrison filling in for rich on the
Rich Eisen show and so my next question
would be Dave Roberts know because we've
seen Clayton kind of stand up answer all
the questions
Dave Roberts answered the questions but
it seemed that this was an analytical
team yeah in the last couple years and
last night they went away from analytics
right they told me ah I went with my gut
and that was different than what you've
told us in years past so how are people
taking that in a situation where you've
been an analytical team and you went
away from it
yeah it could be that this is why I have
always defended him in the past because
I don't believe he coaches with his gut
I think these are a lot of decisions
that are made prior to the game prior to
the series but in those two instances
that I touched on with Clayton Kershaw
gives up that quick home run that is a
hook that means you cannot allow him to
pitch to sotto in that situation and
then you move on to Joe Kelly you cannot
allow him to pitch bases-loaded I mean
so those are two situations that whether
it's gut or not those are decisions that
Dave Roberts cannot make the decisions
that he made I do believe he will be
back I would be shocked if he's not here
but Joe Maddon is available and I'm not
saying that he's the next manager of the
Dodgers I do believe he will begin Los
Angeles one way or the other
but um just those are the two decisions
that I just like I don't know how you
could have watched the team during the
course of the season and felt that that
was the best decision for the team you
know when I knew how you were gonna be
on the show today you were the perfect
person to ask this question because and
and maybe he said it's a tough analogy
but I look at the Lakers right we're
talking on Los Angeles ports and you
look at the Lakers their roster and if
their roster was built like the Dodgers
having having had so much success over
the last three Easons back-to-back World
Series World Series and then this year
there will be a coaching change because
at that time just it's just a pressure
in Los Angeles okay on to the next so
when you tell me that possibly Dave
Roberts comes back what would be the
biggest reason that you bring a coach
back after Gideon because you're going
this way and all of a sudden now seems
like is this team declining are they
still us Cindy I think Friedman likes
the fact that he has a good relationship
with Dave Roberts I've never heard of a
problem between the two of them I think
a lot of the decisions that Dave makes
are in lockstep with what they decide
prior to a game prior to a series but
when you make the high profile game
changing series changing season-ending
decisions that he made it is very hard
for him to keep his job publicly I do
believe when the dust settles you know
cooler heads prevail I do believe he
will be back just because he is the guy
that they believe will make the
decisions that they want I have never
heard of a situation where Dave goes
against what the team
has decided when I say the team is say
say Andrew Friedman and that entire
group but Dave does have it call he does
have a decision and we saw two massive
ones there where you're just watching at
home and even we're watching in the
press box saying wait why is Clinton
still there why is Joe Kelly still in
the bound a rash mark a CLA columnist
joining us you know this is the funny
part because with my background as a
former player in the NFL always knew
that there was somebody who was gonna
get sort of the blame all thrown on him
but at the end of the day I'm at my
locker like man I missed two or three
tackles I mean that guy over there he
missed a block no one talks about that
and so I bring that up because we're
gonna talk about Dave Roberts we're
gonna talk about Clayton Kershaw but
Cody Bellinger or he heard a doubt about
you mentioned Joe Kelly I mean even
Pollak was you one of your offseason AJ
Pollock was your offseason acquisition
and he pretty much went over for the
entire season he [ __ ] for one poor
strikeout it was it was ridiculous Craig
you're 100% right
Will Smith I go back we thought he had a
walk-off home run I mean even he did he
kind of had like a he's kind of flipped
as bad and if they win the game we kind
of forget about all this now we move on
to the next series listen they did not
perform it the whole team did but as you
know in sports if there's one big play
one big moment and there were two of
them
Dave Roberts his decisions Clayton
Kershaw and I just feel so bad for
Clayton Kershaw because of the career
that he's had here and what he's meant
to this team and for him time in and
time I mean just to not perform well
back-to-back home runs her back-to-back
pitches you know I mean we were just
watching that stunned just knowing that
no matter what he does and I don't think
there's a way for him to take back what
happened I think even even if he were to
come back he's the third pitcher on the
team he's not going to get the ball in a
game 7 situation his story his legacy
will be the postseason play off Kershaw
but if I have an opt out and now I'm
moving to Kinley Jansen oh yeah because
here's a guy that I should feel slighted
Here I am is I've been the closer for
this team I've been the guy that when
the game is on the line put me in I've
had some rough patches here and there
but you know in the postseason
been trying to be lights out so he has a
player option for next year what do you
think it can lead Jansen's future with
the diamond he should leave he should
request a change of scenery and by the
way when they played California love and
they're down four runs and he's jogging
to the mound I felt bad for him I felt
bad that he was put in that situation he
did not get the ball in a pressure
situation so they're playing his famous
song that we'd heard listen he put
himself in that position by the way he
performed during the course of this
season but that being said for him not
to get the ball at that moment you know
with a tie game kind of let you know
where were the team views him and if
that's the case that that's fine but
he's good got to go somewhere else
because he could still play I do want to
revisit our poll question because oh yes
I'm glad you brought up because the poll
question I want you to answer so you can
revisit it yeah yeah guys real quick
would you rather lose like the Braves
did a 10 spot in the first it's over
quickly or the Dodgers yesterday down to
the end you had a chance it could have
advanced but you get your heart ripped
out here's why I believe I would rather
have it the way the Dodgers lost I am a
Los Angeles sports fan so that means two
things I arrived to the game slightly
late the game is in hand I leave and I
go home and so what would have happened
and I was picturing a father picking up
his son and saying son we'll get there
in the top of the second don't worry
it's gonna be a great day and how
depressed that father and son would have
been to see a 10 at the bottom of the
first the game is over so if you're a
Los Angeles sports fan maybe you use you
stay for a little bit and then you leave
because that game was over in the first
so I would have hoped to enjoy the game
now you get your heart pulled out you
get your heart ripped out but at least
you would have enjoyed it a little bit
but yeah my next question before we let
you go in here in a minute but so what's
what's next yeah like when you when you
start to look and evaluate the Dodgers
team for 2020 what's the team gonna look
like listen this team is built for
sustained success their core group is
very very young and very talented
they're
problem is they're gonna win the
division going away they're gonna finish
with the best record maybe the
second-best
they gotta get some help in the bullpen
Kirk this is a third year in a row that
they have not been able to hold a lead I
mean you go back to 2017 Kershaw blowing
- not one - full run leads Kenley Jansen
blow in and save a 3-1 game I mean
Walker Buehler no one's talking about
Walker Buehler today I mean what he did
was fantastic so they gotta get some
help in the bullpen but for the most
part the core group I think will be the
same and they're a fantastic young team
but they gotta find a way to win this
it's been 31 years and so now as a LA
Times column man you when do you change
that mindset from all right Dodgers are
over let's focus on the Lakers today I
went to bed at 12:30 I woke up at 4:30
5:30 watch the preseason game with the
Lakers in China going to see the
Clippers tonight know the transition has
begun I was hoping it was gonna be a
little bit later but you got the Lakers
you got the Clippers it's a fun time in
Los Angeles we wish we had some more
postseason baseball but it was not to be
and don't forget the Rams right
roschmann always a play deceiveth thanks
Curt that's a rush mark Ossie LA Times
LA Times columnist joined the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel - 39 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app